flavia kleiner sie ist erst 25 jahre alt
und hat schon viel bewegt in der schweiz
mit ihrem verein operation libero hat
sie einiges zum neuen bei der
durchsetzung initiative beigetragen
jetzt macht sich die geschichtsstudentin
stark für ihre nächste schlacht
wird die schweiz nach
die volksinitiative der svp schweiz
verunmögliche menschlichen verlässlichen
vertragspartnern sie was mir be-
ansprechend sind schweizer recht
stattfände richter nennt die svp ihre
initiative für diese noch bis diesen
herbst unterschriften sammelt lanciert
wurde sie vom juristen hans uli voigt
das heißt immer mich halt das was vor
schluss hat nicht umsetzen will das
übergeordnetem recht widersprechen mit
übergeordnetem recht ist das sogenannte
völkerrecht was will die svp schweizer
recht so die oberste rechts quelle sein
und in zukunft nicht mehr durch den
europäischen gerichtshof für
menschenrechte überprüft und korrigiert
werden können die mitgliedschaft bei der
europäischen menschenrechtskonvention
die die schweiz und weitere 46 länder
unterzeichnet haben würde damit in frage
gestellt
genau darum ist klar wer kleiner nonstop
im einsatz denn ein mehrheitliches ja
bei der abstimmung könnte dazu führen
dass die schweiz die europäische
menschenrechtskonvention kündigen muss
für kleiner ein angriff auf die
grundrechte für mich
insofern mag das sehr wohl verstehe ja
unangenehm sie aber im einzelnen für
mich bedeutet dass möglichkeit zur zu
kommen zusätzlich zu hoch und zu finden
sei nicht eben genau das will die svp
nicht länger akzeptieren dass von volk
und ständen geschaffene recht soll nicht
mehr hinterfragt werden
schweiz die mir selber bestimmen wäre
ich den schweizer bestimmt bürgerinnen
und bürger folgten sonderfall schweiz
darf und soll das volk richter sein
selbst wenn es um komplizierte
sachverhalte geht
flavia kleiner verweist auf eine
unverzichtbare voraussetzung der
modernen demokratie die gewaltenteilung
des gastransits aufgaben verteilt aber
anderseits auch kontrollieren die
verschiedenen aufgabe bestand darin dass
eingesetzt werden muss aber danach
gewann betrachters und für das parlament
legislativer untersten fach und mich an
wiederum gericht wo dann zustande
flavia kleiner verein operation libero
bezieht stellung will aufklären und
einen beitrag zur politischen debatte
leisten ihr anliegen eine schweiz die
welt offen ist zukunftsgewandt die svp
sieht das existenzielle was gilt geht
seine existenz sowie ein mann der selber
will über sich bestimmen
zunächst stand aufgeht kann man schön
dass mit und kassler
dem hält flavia kleiner einen anderen
vergleich entgegen die
europameisterschaft
ja aber nur unter bedingung dass mit
spielerischer definieren und dass wir
einige schiedsrichter stellen play fun
sagt er wollte spielen und das hat sich
schon mit dem interesse für schwächlinge
das völkerrecht die in der
internationalen verständigung aber auch
dem schutz des einzelnen vor
behördenwillkür für flyer kleiner ist es
keine frage dass die schweiz in diesem
regelwerk mitspielen soll europäischen
menschenrechtskonventionen schlechten
freiheitlichen errungenschaften wie es
darum das individuelle recht und
freiheit schützen vor staatlicher
eingriffe und von einer leichtfertigen
abbau von kracht vom einzelnen das war
insofern schwache mainspitze die aktie
wird einfach das ist doch ein echtes
bekenntnis zu den freiheitlichen
errungenschaft mannschaft
das credo der operation libero lautet
wir sind überzeugt dass die schweiz in
besten zeiten noch vor sich hat die
debatte um die initiative wird heftig
werden
es gibt viel zu tun für flavia kleiner